nous accueillons aujourd'hui monsieur
mohamed el hachmi président de
l'université rice l'université ryerson
ces lignes la cité urbaine au coeur de
toronto bonjour monsieur la semi bonjour
merci pour votre habitation
monsieur lachemi votre université
ouvrira en septembre prochain un nouveau
campus
mais cette fois ci ce sera pas quelque
part au canada mais ce sera vraiment à
des milliers de kilomètres d'ici c'est
au caire alors parlez nous de ce projet
je pense que c'est une très très bonne
occasion pour notre université mais
aussi pour notre système d'éducation
d'avoir cette possibilité d'ouvrir des
créneaux de collaboration avec des
institutions ailleurs ils ne sont très
très heureux de nous associer aux
universités du canada en egypte pour
offrir une sélection de programmes qui
sont uniques
on a deux vaincus qui ont commencé qui
vont commencer à offrir des programmes
la première fois que le fait que tu si
la faculté de communication et de design
et la seconde c'est la faculté de génie
et les cours vont commencer banques en
septembre prochain sur magnifique campus
dans la nouvelle ville administrative du
caire
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
comme je les dis c'est quelque chose qui
est très positive pour nommer aussi on
sait que les étudiants du monde entier
ont besoin de compétences pour réussir
dans l'économie du savoir des pronos
mais qui va être de plus en plus basée
sur le savoir et l'innovation et nous ne
sommes pas aussi
nos programmes sont axés sur cette
collaboration avec les employeurs du
monde gentil qui ont besoin de personnel
de 2 d'autres qui sont hautement
qualifiés et dit on sait que les pieds
du monde dont il doit profiter des
opportunités pour surtout un départ
après la pandémie qui causé par cela
c'est parce qu'habituellement c'est les
étudiants qui viennent à l'université à
l'université et là vous allez vers et
vous avez parlé de co2 canada s'est
expliqué il ya une heure une
organisation qui nomi les universités du
canada au caire et cette organisation
avec qui forme il ya deux ans pour
offrir des créneaux pour des universités
canadiennes de et d'offrir des
programmes
donc nous sommes très très heureux 2-2
d'avoir la possibilité de découvrir ce
qu'on puisse au caire en collaboration
avec les universités qui cite une entité
organisation égyptienne
mais le rôle il se devrait décliner à
décrire de collaboration avec des
universités canadiennes
alors dites moi comme je vous ai dit
tantôt habituellement ce sont les
étudiants qui viennent vers vous là vous
allez dans les étudiants pourquoi est-ce
que c'est à cause de la pandémie
c'est quoi les raisons de cette
ouverture je pense qu'il faut être
ouvert dès faut ouvrir les deux
possibilités au canada on a beaucoup
beaucoup d'étudiants étrangers qui
viennent dans les universités
canadiennes
mais on sait qu'avec la pandémie a aussi
des problèmes pour les les étudiants de
2,2 de voyager il ya des plus de plus en
plus de restrictions sur l'obtention de
vie de visas mais aussi pour le les
voyages vous vous allez vous faire
autre campus là bas donc vous engagez la
réputation du de vos diplômes
alors comment se fait le choix des
étudiants et qu'on vous exercer un
contrôle sur vos diplômes pour que vos
diplômes ne soit pas bradé comme ça à
l'international ça c'est une excellente
question
tous nos programmes sont soumis aux
conditions aux mêmes conditions qui pour
les programmes qui sont offerts ici au
canada
donc on fait le refus demandé à des
professeurs selon les mêmes critères
qu'on utilise ici et à halle afin de
d'aider programme les étudiants vont
recevoir un diplôme canadien de notre
université c'est pour cela que au niveau
de la qualité on utilise les mêmes
critères de khalidié qui sont ici et
même au niveau 2 des professeurs on
estime que ces concours sont des
professeurs avoir avoir aussi une
expérience canadien d'où vient cette
réputation de l'université canadienne
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde veut
étudier dans les universités canadiennes
pourquoi je pense au niveau des
universités canadiennes on n'a plus
accès sur le côté pratique
donc on sait que au niveau des études il
ya un aspect théorique et un aspect un
kiki qui est très important mais je
pense des universités canadiennes
offrent cette possibilité de lier un
l'aspect théorique au un besoin de
l'industrie et c'est pour cela que je
pense que nos programmes son compte ils
sont bien cotés sur la scène
internationale mais il ya aussi l'aspect
pratique qui vraiment inefficient au
canada or je reviens à la pandémie
vous en tant qu'université est ce que
vous avez subi une perte d'étudiants
internationaux si je peux dire à cause
de la pandémie parce que vous l'avez
chiffré mais je pense que toutes les
universités canadiennes en ont souffert
à cause de la pandémie non seulement à
cause des étudiants étrangers mais
même ici donc on a au cdd des frais
additionnels qui ont été mises en place
à cause de la pandémie mais je pense que
le gouvernement canadien a offert des
possibilités pour ces étudiants aussi
d'étudier à distance et il ya pas mal
d'étudiants et transition cette année
sont restés dans leur pays d'origine
tout en étudiant à distance offre bien
sûr et à la technologie qui qui s'adapte
à ça mais je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui va à très temporaire c'est pas
quelque chose qui va être long terme
parce que les gens qui veulent étudier
ici ils veulent aussi l'expérience
canadienne est aussi le côté structurel
sociale
je pense que c'est des cons qui sont
importants
cette expérience qu'ont offert qu'on va
offert aux étudiants étrangers
est ce que vous prévoyez de ce
partenariat dans le monde là vous avez
dans la région moyen orient afrique du
nord est ce que il ya d'autres
partenaires par ailleurs je pense que ça
va être une
on espère et on on sait que ça ça ça il
ya un besoin qui tiennent pourtant pour
des étudiants locaux qui veulent rester
dans leur pays mais avoir accès à des à
une expérience soit une utilisation
canadien je pense qu'il ya d'autres
régions du monde où on sait que le la
réputation du canada et ses notes
partout je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
régions du monde
il ya une demande il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui a qui sont très très
intéressé par le système éducatif au
canada j'espère que ça va être une bonne
expérience pour nous pour continuer
d'explorer d'autres pays d'autres
d'autres régions du monde et je pense
que dans les prochaines années
vous allez
entendre d'autres d'autres partis
derrière il trompe us à travers le monde
merci beaucoup monsieur la chemise je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'université ryerson merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
merci beaucoup